aquí tengo una elipse graficada y lo que
vamos a tratar de hacer es hallar su
ecuación por lo cual como siempre te
invito a que hagas una pausa y trates de
resolver este problema por tu propia
cuenta
muy bien primero recordemos cuál es la
forma de la ecuación de una elipse y
primero digamos vamos a hablar de
generalidades y luego ya nos
adentraremos a la forma particular de la
ecuación de este elipse entonces digamos
que nuestra elipse tiene centro con
coordenadas h coma acá muy bien vamos a
suponer también que nuestra elipse tiene
un radio horizontal que a veces también
llamamos el eje horizontal verdad tiene
un radio horizontal y este radio vale a
esto tiene valor a y vamos a suponer
también que tiene un radio vertical
tiene un radio vertical y el valor del
radio vertical será de muy bien entonces
con esto como construimos la ecuación de
nuestra elipse bueno pues esto
simplemente sera
menos la coordenada h del centro verdad
y eso lo elevamos al cuadrado y luego
dividimos entre el radio horizontal al
cuadrado bien luego sumamos ye menos la
coordenada la segunda coordenada del
centro verdad que en este caso sería que
todo esto elevado al cuadrado y dividido
entre b cuadrada y esto tiene que ser
igual a 1 muy bien esta es la fórmula
general y a partir de ésta podemos
deducir cuál es la fórmula particular de
este elipse entonces para este caso
particular nosotros tenemos este centro
de verdad
este centro tiene coordenadas menos 4
menos 4 y en una altura de 3 muy bien
entonces las coordenadas del centro
serán menos 4 y 3 así que aquí iría
-4 aquí iría tres muy bien ahora cuál es
el valor del radio horizontal es decir
estamos pensando en esta longitud verdad
que va del centro hasta este otro punto
y estos son 1 2 3 4 5 verdad entonces
nuestro valor de a en este caso es 5 así
que aquí podríamos poner 5 al cuadrado y
si pensamos ahora en el radio vertical
es decir estamos pensando en esta
longitud que desde cuatro unidades
verdad uno dos tres cuatro entonces ve
en este caso es igual a cuatro y
podríamos sustituir aquí con cuatro muy
bien entonces vamos a escribir esta
ecuación esto nos quedaría como x menos
menos cuatro verdad
vamos a usar el mismo color menos cuatro
y eso lo podríamos simplificar en unos
minutos
todo esto elevado al cuadrado dividido
entre 5 al cuadrado que es 25
luego sumamos sumamos y menos la
coordenada cada verdad que en este caso
es 3
en -3 todo esto elevado al cuadrado
dividido entre b cuadrada pero en este
caso ves 4 así que queda 16 y esto debe
ser igual a 1 muy bien y por supuesto
podríamos todavía simplificar esto
verdad porque x menos menos 4
simplemente lo podemos dejar como x más
4 x + 4 muy bien entonces ahí lo tienes
esta es la ecuación de nuestra elipse